let's jump to the story about Andrew
Tate because we've got this breaking
footage Benny Johnson posted at breaking
news Andrew Tate and Tristan are freed
from prison and so here we can see
they're just they're coming out unshaven
and then we have this other video that
people were mentioning Andrew take
tweets since last year I've been in
24-hour lockdown no yard time pacing a
three meter cell with zero Electronics
or outside contact absolute Clarity of
Mind real thoughts real plans Vivid pain
one hour home and I can't stand my phone
some habits die hard we must defeat
shaytan and then people are pointing out
that he was he was not sitting around
doing nothing he was he was working out
he is a member of the clean play club
that man has been eating a lot of food
and doing a lot of push-ups I would love
to talk to Andrew if you're out there
Andrew so he's on house arrest now he
and Tristan have been moved from the
jail cell to house arrest
yeah so I think we got to hear from The
Daily Mail they say freed Andrew take
claimed he is now absolute Clarity of
thought an ecstatic tank Etc et cetera
they walked into the Bucharest jail
together uh let's see uh uh where is the
they like putting all this puff stuff in
here
leave that or left uh Romania in jail
can you give me the news on what what
this is all about it's hard to pull it
up when it's like the last minute but uh
well there you go the bail application
was rejected on Wednesday all four
appealed the decision today the court of
appeal in Bucharest ruled that the
brothers and two alleged accomplices
would be released from prison a place
under house arrest the spokesman for the
Tate Brothers exclusively told
mailonline were ecstatic to announce the
Romanian Judicial System approved Andrew
and Tristan Tate's appeal against last
week's extension uh decision they will
be placed under house arrest while the
investigation continues so my
understanding is still they've never
been charged with any crimes and they
have women who have come out and
testified
in their defense and a judge ruled no
you're brainwashed so to see him be
released it's crazy I said good I
tweeted and these lefties are like oh
but haven't you seen the things he said
I'm like dude
he could have said the worst thing in
the world he could have said the worst
things in the world he could have gone
on the most vile Rants and what would I
have to say about that wow I really
don't like those guys opinions however
he wasn't charged with any crime so why
are they locking him up I get it it's
Romania okay so it's not the United
States but my moral standard regardless
of the law is don't lock people in boxes
that you have no evidence of wrongdoing
they're not even accusing of wrongdoing
100 you know I wasn't even a follower of
Andrew tase I didn't know much about him
until all this happened and the day he
got arrested I was hanging out with my
my friend Eddie and uh you know Eddie's
just your your typical 20 some year old
dude he's like I love Andrew Tate this
guy speaks the truth the guy did nothing
wrong I'm like dude how do you know for
a fact he's like he did nothing wrong
and so I started looking into the case
because of uh Eddie and
um then he had the alleged victims his
abuse victims that said I wasn't abused
at all like Andrew did nothing wrong and
Tristan did nothing wrong and it's just
another example of persecution of
anybody that that questions the regime
and did somebody in the United States
state department make a phone call to
Romania and encourage them to take care
of the Andrew Tate problem because he's
becoming too influential in America you
never know and we don't have too much
faith in the actors at the state
department when in our government to
make when two women come out and say
we're accused of being victims but we
will testify under oath this is not true
and a judge says don't care I'm like
some fish is going on at least get a
psychoval on the girls no no no like if
you don't believe them I can respect
that but we don't psych eval Witnesses
exculpatory Witnesses not in the U.S we
don't and I think that that should apply
everywhere and I know Roman is different
I know it's their own law but my
standard is not based on legality it's a
moral standard of yo come on what though
you're brainwashed you don't count like
two women with adult human brains have
told you they're not victims that's it
well on January 6 president Trump said
peacefully and patriotically protest and
then you know people disregarded what he
said in his actual speech and then they
said he incited Violence by saying those
words so like the the regime doesn't
really care they make up and they
try to throw anybody that they deem a
threat in jail you know I watched a
Tucker Carlson tonight uh interview with
Tucker and Andrew Tate and you know
everybody said Andrew Tates the
misogynist he's crazy he's this he's
that and I listened and he's very
articulate he's well spoken and he has
convictions and
um you know they're just throwing him in
jail because his message is resonating
with others and it sounds like another
guy I know they it's it's kind of poetic
that the day they let out one guy that
questions the regime and and the regime
hates they try to arrest another so and
they they also let Jacob chancelly out
yesterday or the day before he's the the
Q Shaman from January 6th there was
evidence came out that Tucker Carlson
showed the video of two weeks ago or so
but but now he's out but his release was
scheduled oh and so as large like no no
this was his normal time to be at least
nine months earlier or something like to
like a halfway house or something thing
like that and then what was it he
tweeted or something he tweeted
yesterday I always saw I saw it in my
feed it had 16 000 likes or something
and then my feed like Auto refreshed
which is a big problem on Twitter you
guys got to fix that yeah and it
disappeared in his channel I can't find
his channel real real quick someone
super chatted Matt says to go to New
York City a lot are you gonna you're
gonna go up to New York on Tuesday when
Trump's supposed to be indicted yeah
I'll be there yeah let's let's get it
let's let's let's figure it out anyway
let's go back to what we're talking
about I was just excited by that I'm
like oh man we definitely got to have
you up there I don't know while we're
talking about January 6 characters I
think one of the greatest characters
ever was the lectern guy oh yeah he was
on the show and I just realized he
follows me on Twitter so like they call
him Podium guy but it was a lectern so
it's like it's elected so at at lectern
leader on Twitter that guy's a goat for
real lectern leader and there's Adam
Johnson there was a situation where Ron
DeSantis was at a campaign event and
somebody took his Podium and he's crying
where's my Podium go where did I Podium
go and there was a meme of lecterno
taking away the podium I'm like this guy
awesome so lectern leader he served his
time in jail I don't think he should
have ever gone
um but you know lectern leader and the Q
Shaman Let My People Go Joe Biden
for sure man a mass pardon and I'm
talking about across the aisle no and
setting down tensions that's where you
lose me buddy squeezing tighter I don't
think that's how we win dude you don't
win by getting kicked in the face
repeatedly until you're on the ground
and go thanks buddy I forgive you well
that's how you win friends
those deal with it so on
January 6 I'm 23 years old I don't know
too much about anything I'm in
Washington DC for the protest I'm a
trump supporter I have questions about
the election
two years go by almost a year and a half
goes by don't hear from anybody all of a
sudden I get an email from you know I'm
like I feel bad I have a pit in my
stomach I feel bad for what's going on
to a lot of these January 6 protesters I
decide to make an announcement I'm going
to donate fifty thousand dollars to help
j6 political prisoners
two days after I make this pledge and it
goes public
I get an email from a guy named Sean
tanoli from the January 6 committee Alex
we believe you have information related
to January 6th and we would like to
speak with you I go on Tucker Carlson
the next couple of days I tell him the F
off in a nice way they subpoena me I
have no knowledge about January 6. zero
whatsoever they subpoena me they forced
me to spend tens of thousands of dollars
they dragged me before the Congressional
committee Adam kinzinger is the only
member that shows up I'm wearing a
subpoenaed hat because I'm like
but they forced me a guy who's trying to
have a future have a family one day they
forced me to spend tens of thousands of
dollars to defend myself over
so when we get back power I don't really
want to have peace with these people who
did this to us and are continuing to do
this to us I think that we have to turn
the tables on them give them a dose of
their own medicine and then we can even
the playing field and then we can
discuss Unity they've got look people
who broke the law go to jail and the
issue is they're saying oh Donald Trump
in this this indictment blah blah blah
misdemeanor charge does not feel real
they have falsely accused Trump of being
a Russian spy one dude went on MSNBC and
said he worked for the Soviet Union that
Trump may have been an asset of the
Russian since the 80s which was the
Soviet Union and it's just like
you're insane this is not real you have
lost your minds so when they're doing
this I'm just like I don't care I don't
believe it they get no benefit of the
doubt from me but that what they're
doing is unprecedented now what we need
is I'll put it simply I will be
satisfied right now if Trump goes in and
schedule F fires everybody schedule F
right yeah just fire them all and look
into that fire because I don't care I
don't care if they're criminals okay if
they're not we need term limits for
bureaucrats we can't have permanent
government actors because then you end
up with a permanent government well what
if he creates a law that creates term
limits for bureaucrats
what if he works with Congress to create
a law rather than firing people no he
creates a law that makes them their
careers terminated
clean them out and then clean out the
existing bureaucracy then if there's if
Congress wants to pass legislation
talking about uh term limits or
something I would I would endorse that
kind of stuff well but get rid of the
bad apples that are in there now and if
you get rid of some good app apples
getting rid of bad apples it's fine
you're not putting people in jail you're
not killing people you're just firing
people they'll go find jobs in some
other field hopefully whatever they
they're all probably millionaires
anyways or at least have plenty of money
they fire them all these bureaucrats
probably make decent money yeah and and
we should just it's not I'll put it this
way I'll meet you halfway in it's not
personal it's not punishment it's we
have to reset the permanent government
but what we don't want a permanent
government so we're going to terminate
these jobs we're going to set a new law
a new standard saying you can only work
for the government for x amount of years
then we're going to rehire from fresh to
to just clean house but what concerns me
is an Art of War metaphor is that
there's a large advancing enemy in front
of you you're like I don't like that
enemy everyone we're severely
outnumbered everyone Advance direct
attack on what we don't like like just
doing the brute straightforward thing is
not the way you win against this we're
not talking about violence though no I'm
talking about firing no it's a metaphor
of how you handle business yeah and and
so it's
other countries eliminate their entire
governments or at least don't tell them
you're going to do it before you do it
they're they're there are because then
they know it's
nothing it's gonna run on that he's got
to get elected on that and he has to
tell the American people that he's going
to do that it is better for him to say
hey look I'm telling the American people
this is what I'm running on then he gets
elected then he has a mandate from the
American people he can say to the
bureaucracy hey look the American people
elected me for the specific purpose of
firing all your asses thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time